your mission should you choose to accept  it I wonder did you choose not to the  end nor was feared is coming and the  blood will be on your hands the fallout  of all your good intentions you had a  terrible choice to make in Berlin one  life over millions and now the world is  at risk this is the CIA's mission if he  had held on to the plutonium we wouldn't  be having this conversation this Tim  you'd be dead yes they would that's the  job  [Music]  you don't understand what you're  involved in you need to walk away please  don't make me cuts for you how many  times as hunts government's betrayed him  disavowed him cast him aside how long  before a man like that has had enough  even though we are  so how is he oh you know same always  there  what the hell is he doing find it best  not to hook  [Music]